[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
please give a warm iowa welcome to the
one
and only joe exotic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to
the best exotic animal show in these
united states
i'm telling you folks you're going to
see animals like you've never seen them
before up close and personal it'll be
closer than that time you walked in on
mom and dad and they said it was just
wrestling sure looked like dad was
winning though didn't it
i'm going to introduce you to a friend
right now cletus come on out here
oh i don't know this is how i like to
say hello to cletus thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you know cletus might kiss like he's
french but i guaran god damn tia he's
100 arabian right cletus what
ah
oh my
clitoris said forget about all them
sikhs in the middle east there ain't no
better place to be in the world than the
lynn county fair with y'all
i want you to talk to cletus he'll talk
back to you in his own special way i'll
be right back what the give it i'm
getting warmed up i got a problem
he's been throwing up
just
pump him full of antibiotics and we got
to get him on stage he can't go on joe
he's my headliner well he needs a vet so
unless you can magically pull the tiger
out of your ass
you're screwed
got it
the orange give me the orange
relax
this is gonna come out
i
think
who wants to see a tiger appear out of
thin air
i can't hear you
[Applause]
all right your wish is my command
[Applause]
yeah well my friend might be young but
pretty soon he can be eating 333 pounds
on me a month that'll clean out any
mcdonald's
what's better than seeing a tiger
it's petting one who's ready for the
next part of the show i know you are
god damn it
mother
sheep
you